je veux mettre au cours de cette
commission d' enquête parlementaire sur
le chlordécone et le paraquat beaucoup
des scientifiques auditionné en
minimiser les liens possibles entre
pesticides et cancer de la prostate
tout comme le président de la république
lui-même c'était en février dernier
pendant le grand débat national
il ya des prévalences qui ont été
reconnues scientifiquement et là je
parle sous le contrôle de la ministre
est médecin donc elle me complétera ou
ne corrigera mais je pense qu'il faut
pas aller jusqu'à dire c'est cancérigène
parce qu'à la fois on dit quelque chose
qui n'est pas vrai et on alimente les
peurs à la fin de cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire jeudi le directeur
général de la santé en charge de la
politique de santé publique va pourtant
adopté une position courageuse salle
d'un scientifique d'un épidémiologiste
comme il a tenu à le rappeler
au début de son audition pourquoi dieu
ou jours lui qui est au club lien entre
cancer de la prostate et plus on déconne
est ce que vous partagez je conduis je
n'ai jamais dit s'est prononcé cette
phrase le président très bien vous
n'avez pas liés bon vous l'avez pas dit
je suis maintenant je n'ai jamais
prononcé cette phrase que je puisse que
j'avais entendu de maintenant non je
pense que c'est très important parce que
là les antillais sont inquiets personne
ne dit que circulez ya rien à voir
pour enfoncer le clou le professeur
multigner de passage en guadeloupe
faisaient aujourd'hui une mise au point
il a dirigé avec le docteur pascal
blanchet l'étude karuprostate il
rappelle que l'inserm publiait il ya
quinze jours encore un rapport public de
70 pages issu des travaux d'une dizaine
d'experts connue et reconnue et qui
confirme le lien entre le pesticide et
la maladie on peut pas mener en bateau
la population qui ont des changes
noir un jour blanc un jour gris jeu
qu'on ne sait pas de quelle couleur on
va se réveiller
je crois qu'il faut de la transparence
il peut y avoir du débat scientifique
mais le débat scientifique
il doit être public et entre personnes
mois sur ces questions je n'ai pas
d'interlocuteur nous n'avons pas
d'interlocuteur
alors les paroles sont là on se demande
des faits 163 cas pour 100000 en voile
ou 161 cas pour 100000 en martinique ce
sont les chiffres de la prévalence du
cancer de la prostate
dans l'hexagone elle est de 98 pour cent
mille hommes